les États-Unis voulaient que le Canada
en barque mais vous vous avez fait
quelque chose qui fait encore jaser
aujourd'hui les experts en politique
vous avez refusé jusqu'à quel point ça
prenait du courage pour dire non aux
Américains il y avait des pressions
c'est clair il voulait que les pays près
des États-Unis face la guerre mais pour
nous on a dit non pourquoi parce que ils
avaient tort et les l'histoire prouvé
que nous avons eu raison évidemment les
pressions étaient très grandes non
seulement de Joyce wow mais de tourner
Blair aussi et qui était un ami et on a
eu des conversations ça a duré pendant
des mois et à tout le temps je leur
disais il vous faut avoir le
consentement des Nations Unies et dans
dans mon esprit à moi et suivant les
documents que j'ai consulté il n'y a pas
de preuves qu'il y a des armements de
destruction massive il y en a pas cher
que je le faire parce que il pensait pas
que le Canada allait dire non c'était la
première fois qu'il y avait une guerre
où les Américains et les Britanniques
étaient impliqués et que le Canada n'y
était pas alors évidemment ici au Canada
l'opinion était très divisé il y en
avait beaucoup qui voulait pas qu'on a
la guerre mais par contre il y avait des
gens qui s'inquiétaient énormément en
particulier les hommes d'affaires qui
avaient peur que les Américains se
vengent contre nous et là toutes ces
pressions là
nous avons décidé de dire non et puis
l'histoire a prouvé qu'on avait eu
raison parce que c'est un désastre dans
le Moyen-Orient depuis ce temps-là et il
y a eu les conséquences considérables
changer l'équilibre qui existait à
l'époque dans cette partie troublée du
monde et pour nous on a dit non et les
gens aujourd'hui reconnaissent qu'on a
pris la bonne décision ensuite content
vous parlez ça comme c'était facile
aujourd'hui il va être plus tard
Monsieur chrétien mais dans les fils
plongez-nous un petit peu dans ce que ça
voulait dire pour vous à l'époque il y a
20 ans quand vous dites les États-Unis
faisaient pression sur moi on m'a
présenté des preuves on me présenter des
documents comment ça se passait vos
échanges avec Monsieur bouche là-dessus
d'abord c'était le mois d'août
il y avait une rencontre entre le mois
d'août précédent la guerre à des trois
la frontière entre le président et moi
et il avait mis une heure et demie de
côté pour me recevoir et on était seul
je t'avais pas de conseiller lui non
plus et j'ai dit clairement quelques
minutes que ce que je pensais
on avait trop tard pour discuter enfin
qu'on a fini la conversation en parlant
de football puis de baseball on avait
plus rien nager parce que j'avais dit
clairement si vous avez pas les nations
vous avez présenté monsieur chrétien de
vous convaincre on dit regarder on a des
preuves on a du renseignement ici
qu'est-ce qu'on peut jouer vous avez vu
vous avez vu il y avait pas qui était le
secrétaire d'État qui est fait un grand
discours aux Nations Unies on voyait des
camions qui partaient d'un endroit en
Irak pour aller à l'autre et moi j'avais
vu les mêmes choses mais c'est pas
convaincant hier avec quelque chose qui
m'avait intrigué j'ai trouvé drôle que
celui qui
amenait les armements de destruction
massive de d'une ville à l'autre parle
de ça au téléphone il y aurait pu dire
c'est les meubles de la belle-mère qui
s'en vont mais pas de dire c'est des
armements de destruction massive mais si
vous voulez faire croire qu'il y en a
c'est une bonne technique
moi j'avais dit à l'époque dans un de
mes livres que il y avait pas cette
preuve convaincre le juge de la Cour
municipale Shawinigan alors
Monsieur bouche
l'équivalent le problème que nous avions
aussi c'est que la communauté financière
était morte de pas il va pas que en fait
85 % de nos affaires avec les États-Unis
alors les affaires ils avaient peur que
les yeux que les États-Unis ça va je
compte nous et rien qui est arrivé de ce
côté là j'avais rencontré des hommes
d'affaires et je leur avais dit
donnez-moi la liste des biens
et des services que les Américains
achètent de nous qui ont pas besoin
puis on achète qu'on a besoin c'est les
affaires sont les affaires et la défense
et la politique internationale c'est
d'autres choses qu'est-ce que vous
compreniez à l'époque des véritables
motivations des Américains pour éliminer
cette invasion en Irak
jamais j'avais une conversation avec ton
éber
en Afrique du Sud on avait une réunion
en Afrique du Sud après enfin la journée
j'étais allé prendre une bière avec lui
et il y avait aussi madame Clark qui
était la première ministre de la
Nouvelle-Zélande et quelques adjoints et
là il y a essayé de me convaincre mais
ce qui m'avait impressionné c'est que
alors que George Bush me parlait
d'armement de destruction massive donnez
lui m'a dit non il faut se débarrasser
de Saddam Hussein c'est un terrible
dictateur alors j'avais répondu au
Premier ministre
si on doit se mettre à remplacer les
chefs qu'on n'aime pas dans le monde
entier pourquoi qu'on règle pas le
problème juste voisin ici au Zimbabwe
Mugabe très populaire dans le monde
international et il m'a dit que
c'est pas la même chose et j'ai dit je
ne sais pas la même chose donner Mugabe
pétrole
pendant un an je pense qu'il m'a pas
parlé après ça donc vous pensez que le
pétrole était aussi
président des
États du pétrole c'était quand qu'il a
quitté son emploi il y avait une on
l'avait donné une paye pour quitter de
millions de dollars et devenu
vice-président alors il travaillait dans
le pétrole pour la liberté qui je pense
et nous la compagnie la plus grande
contracteur
dans les
pétrole et aussi dans l'armement du
Texas alors c'était difficile à faire
parce que on sait jamais les
conséquences si ça avait été un énorme
succès
de la fou un peu et mais je croyais que
mes informations étaient bonnes et
qu'ils avaient tort de faire la guerre à
ce moment-là pour les raisons qui nous
donnaient avez-vous des contacts aussi à
l'époque avec le président français
monsieur Chirac parce que lui aussi
tenait être aux Américains oui j'ai
parlé avec Chirac aussi je parlais avec
d'autres
de l'Allemagne et aussi la carte le
moment où j'ai dit non c'était dans le
mois de mars alors le Canada n'était
plus au Conseil de sécurité depuis le
mois de décembre mais on était très
impliqué avant et notre ambassadeur qui
était excellent a continué à être
impliqué et là c'était le Mexique qui
nous avait remplacé sur le Conseil de
sécurité et avec ensuite le Chili et
c'était deux nouveaux présidents la
grâce au Chili et fax
au Mexique et eux ils m'appelaient et
puis moi je le dis il m'a plus ou moins
dit si tu ne vas pas
on n'ira pas et ça George Bush m'avait
dit que quand influence pas les autres
mais j'ai dit écoutez c'est George il
m'appelle vous connaissez chrétien il va
répondre au téléphone et je leur ai
donné mon opinion d'ailleurs et la grâce
est faxe des circonstances tout à fait
particulière après tout ça mon remercie
publiquement de les avoir aidés à
prendre cette décision là d'ailleurs la
gars c'était venu le faire nul autre
place cachée
comment est-ce que c'était plus froid
est-ce que vous parlez encore
il était un homme
différenti et qui était toujours la
taille et tout ça comme moi d'ailleurs
et il avait les opinions et les
exprimaient mais il argumentait pas
beaucoup et si vous étiez pas d'accord
très bien
ça prenait sa planète du temps puis il
voulait toujours vous convaincre c'est
très intéressant parce qu'il était très
érudit mais George lui c'est un homme
qui disait ou bien puis toi tu disais
noire qu'on s'entend pas alors parlons
d'autre chose et
ce qu'il m'a dit un jour c'est son chef
de cabinet qui m'avait dit ça il dit on
vous voyait faire
et on faisait de la journée le Canada va
être là mais chrétien
vieux politicien
renard comme des gens disent et qui qui
s'est entrain de se positionner on était
pris par ce prix quand vous avez dit non
parce qu'on pensait vous allez dire oui
ils m'ont dit
on est déjà pointé mais vous nous avez
pas trahi vous vous nous l'avez toujours
dit que vous seriez probablement pas là
d'autre nous ont dit qu'il sera avec
nous et les autres nous ont trahi pas
vous vous avez été clair et puis on est
déjà pointé mais vous ne savez pas trahi
alors par la suite on a continué
on a beaucoup de problèmes ça devient
c'est pas des choses personnelles très
souvent on faut s'élever au dessus de
chat moi je représentais le Canada
j'étais Premier ministre j'étais pas
d'accord avec lui et d'abord j'ai dit
non et puis quand vous pensez à ça 20
ans plus tard êtes-vous fier de ce que
vous avez fait à ce moment-là
plus tard de nous dire comment ça se
passait derrière les porte-clés c'est
toujours très intrigant bien entendu
merci j'ai eu beaucoup de plaisir
pendant longtemps ça me fait plaisir de
partager avec vous ce soir encore une
fois merci de m'avoir écouté au revoir
et à bientôt au revoir